welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and a big plot
leaked from OBS has just hit the web
it's currently putting the internet in a
spin and after it was apparently
verified on subreddit Marvel Studios
spoilers it looks like it has a lot of
weight to it throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down the entire plot
talking about what it teases and giving
our opinion on whether it sucks or not
get it because he's a vampire anyway
other than terrible puns there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined about the
movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now as with the recent birds of
prey pot leaked these can sometimes be
very accurate and we don't want to ruin
the movie for anybody so this is your
last chance to turn off you're still
here I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking the video now let's get
into the breakdown of the Morbius plot
leak okay so the port leak was posted by
reddit user throw away five seven three
seven two nine not 69s and I'll not read
out the entire number who said that they
didn't want to reveal how they knew any
of this in order to protect their
identity and mod two then later posted
that they had privately messaged them to
verify how they knew it and it's rare
that things like this get posted on the
subreddit so it adds a lot of validity
to it I've rewritten part of it for the
video just so it doesn't sound like I'm
reading a bunch of sentences but I'll
leave a link below if you want to check
out the entire thing anyway the user
said the film opens with Michael Morbius
being awarded a Nobel Prize for his
involvement in medical research during
his acceptance speech the character
falls over and faints the film link cuts
to black and it shows Michael as a young
child at school being bullied because he
can't walk this is then broken up by
immune ekeus who is a doctor working at
the school according to these leaks the
character finally has a name and he
isn't dr. octopus Emile was actually the
best friend of Michael in the comics so
this ties heavily in with his origin
story we then cut to adult Michael
having a discussion with Niko's he
explains that his disease is getting
worse and he suspects he doesn't have
long left to live he thanks Niko's for
sticking with him throughout his life
and it's
to be a really touching moment the pot
League jumps back and forward through
time showing not only current events but
also Morbius is past we then jump back
to young Michael in a hospital ward
playing chess against Nico's NICUs
encourages Michael to pursue becoming a
doctor in order to find a cure for his
disease Niko's is then told he has to
see another patient and Michael
continues playing chess by himself I
don't know why that's in the plotly it
didn't really make a difference but
anyway back in the present we see
Michael in hospital in New York helping
a young girl who has cancer he stopped
by the sighs crown I don't know if a
butchered his name there so I've got to
keep calling him Crone throughout the
video who Michael doesn't know crown
gives him a briefcase and his card and
then he tells Michael that these may
help him to find a cure we then jump
forward in time to Michael being
injected his medication by his wife
Martine Bancroft I don't know why his
wife has a different name but I suppose
it is 2020 during this scene Michael
explains once again how he suspects he
doesn't have long to live Michael and
Bancroft walk to their lab and Michael
says he needs to try more radical ways
to cure himself Michael opens the
briefcase and inside discovers a dead
bat and a giant knife
Michael is confused but studies it and
finds out it's a vampire bat this leaves
a lot of things up in the air and starts
him on a journey to discover what's
going on his wife leaves and Michael
calls crown and asks about the artifacts
crown explains that he once suffered
from the same disease and tells him
about a cave in Brazil that will help to
cure him Bancroft warns against it but
Michael doesn't listen and he goes there
anyway this is when we see the
helicopter seen from the trailer with
the character on the way to the cave
there's a voiceover from crown whilst
this is happening that explains what
Michael has to do once he arrives there
he pays everyone off and some kind of
machine opens up from the ground
Michael cuts his hand and presses it
against these strings within the machine
and bats fly towards him and then out of
the cave this kills everyone else that
was in the helicopter and Michael passes
out and we cut to black we join Michael
as he wakes up and wanders around Brazil
from here he sneaks onto a cargo ship
headed to New York and realizes that
he's slowly transforming into a vampire
the ship is attacked by pirates and this
becomes the film's first real action
scene Mobius starts by killing them off
and it's meant to portray him as a
monster hunting them this is a similar
sort of thing to the predator scene from
Batman Begins with a perspective of the
pirates being mainly what we see at the
end of the scene we get a good look at
him and it's a shot from the trailers
Morbius then jumps off the ship and
starts swimming towards the shore he
wakes up in New York and crawls into a
bar and tells the bartender to call him
an ambulance he's unsure of exactly
what's happened but has a feeling that
something terrible is going on it's
during the scene that Michael watches
the TV and on it is none other than Jay
jonah Jameson talking about dead bodies
mysteriously found on a cargo ship
Michael Leng gets flashbacks to the
attack and realizes he did it the
ambulance arrives and when he's rushed
to the hospital he tells everyone that
he was mugged and his crutches were
stolen once he's in his lab he tells
Bancroft and Niko's what really happened
and he locks himself in a container to
protect them Michaels thirst for blood
becomes too strong and he breaks out
Bancroft and Niko's managed to escape
but he runs after a doctor working there
and is shot by security guards
Bancroft manages to tranq him and he's
then subdued from here Michael wakes up
in his lab and finds a tomb there
there's no onion that says all of the
answers you seek lie within and it's
written by Crown well well it says it's
written by Louis but you know I hate
that name Michael opens it up to find a
skeleton wearing a comic accurate
Morbius suit which he then laughs at so
yeah another case of the studio taking a
dump on the source material the tomb is
also covered in some ancient language
and Michael doesn't know how but he's
able to read it from here we could to
simon Stroud play by Tyrese Gibson who's
investigating what caused the death of
the pirates
Simon believes it was something
supernatural which the other cops laugh
at Simon also has a mechanical gauntlet
on his right arm
that gives him super-strength it's
mentioned that the Gorna is from Oscorp
which is our first big tease at the
biggest spider-verse I'm not gonna lie
when I first read that I was very happy
and I do hope that it's true meanwhile
there's a montage of Michael testing out
his new abilities and apparently a lot
of this is seen in the trailers
Simon visit sneaked us and starts asking
him questions about Michael meanwhile
crown is in some sort of lab in the
sewers and is revealed to be incredibly
skinny and has tattoos all over his body
we then cut to the tomb in Michaels lab
opening itself up and this is a big
action scene in which the character
fights the skeleton according to the
redditor this is the best scene in the
movie just because of how bonkers it is
Morbius defeats it by crushing its skull
and then the skeleton costume attaches
itself to Morbius crown wakes up and
cast a spell on himself and then he
walks into some train tracks and stops a
train with a weird magical spell he then
sucks the life out of everyone on board
and till he regains his strength and
looks like Matt Smith once more crown
senses that Simon Stroud is going to
ruin his plans and he possesses Morbius
who flies over then he causes house to
kill Stroud Stroud is able to put up a
fight with Morbius because of the
gauntlet and Nichols is killed during it
this massive death in the movie makes
Michael snap out of it and he allows
Stroud to arrest him so similar to the
comic books
Niko's dies but it doesn't mention
whether he's a victim of Morbius like
the source material but hey at least
it's similar he's then sent to San
Quentin State Prison and his cell mate
is Adrian Toomes
who makes a joke about how him getting
blipped meant he got a shorter sentence
so they are acknowledging the snap in
this according to the leak and we know
that they are definitely tying it in
with the bigger MCU during the night
Michael sees crown in some kind of ghost
form and he tells him to meet him in New
York or he'll kill Martine Michael
builds up his powers and breaks out the
prison while flowing and being
surrounded by bats this somehow leads to
all the electricity being cut off within
the prison and everyone is set free
right happens in which many escape and
we see tombs climb up the prison while
Michael uses his powers against the
prison guards and steals the coat from
one of them tombs thanks Michael for
breaking him out and he tells him he's
putting a team together and wants him to
join Michael declines and uses a
SuperSpeed to take him back to New York
so we have our first hint at the
sinister six finally it does look like
if this plot leak is true the movie is
setting up a lot of things with this and
Oscorp both playing big roles you
see Matt Gaughan breakout and me up with
Toombs Cletus Kasady also runs off and
this shows that going ahead there are
going to be villains for both venom and
Spidey to fight the user says that in
regards to carnage that thankfully his
hair no longer resembles Sideshow Bob
and looks more like a mop and slightly
less red it still looks like a big wig
but they say it's better than what we
had in Benham Morbius finds crown in New
York who reveals that he was once the
skeleton and he's actually here because
of reincarnation he says he needs more
vyas to complete a ritual so he can live
forever
and become more powerful Morbius his
costume forms around him and he fights
crown the reddit has said that they fly
a lot of the time and that this scene
reminded them a lot of the fight from
the end of Chronicle Morbius is able to
defeat crown by reading one of his
tattoos which allows him to suck the
life out of him Morbius grows until he's
9 feet tall and starts roaring at
everyone but Bancroft calms him down
until he's normal again
Morbius escapes before the police
arrives and he takes off his costume on
the way he passes the Spider Man poster
tag murderer and unlike in the trailer
the picture used resembles the
homecoming suit instead of the rainy one
the film ends with Michael and Bancroft
at necrosis funeral while Stroud watches
in the distance we then cut to Morbius
jumping across New York and the final
shot is with the living vampire on a
billboard showing a Peter Parker Wanted
sign the user says there are no end
credits scenes so that's the entire plot
leaked and honestly if this turns out to
be true then I'll be extremely happy it
seems to be taking all of the boxes for
me in providing an interesting story but
it also sets up big things to come down
the line I'm massively happy with this
and some of the MC references outlined
here are great not only does it provide
a satisfying pot I feel it also dropped
some big nods to the sinister six and by
the sounds of this this is gonna be a
great entry in the spider-verse
overall I'm actually really high for the
film now and this leak has definitely
got me a lot more excited for it when it
releases obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leak and if you believe
it's true or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our recent comic book break
of some of the insane details that you
missed in the Benjie's endgame we go
over the craziest Easter eggs that I
haven't seen many people talking about
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to
support the channel from its let this 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below you get access to content
early and can also suggest video topics
and breakdowns massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made gonna come chat just
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
who are subscribed to the channel and
this Monty can win dr. sleep and all you
have to do is comment on a video and
make sure you sub with notifications on
the more videos you comment on the more
you have a chance of winning and the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of February so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you